hello everyone i would like to welcome
those who have just joined hi fortune
and uh
hello abhishek
we will be starting this session at the
scheduled time we are waiting for others
to join as well
meanwhile we begin advent i think we
have met before as well but abhishek
anshul and
fortune could you please tell us about
your background and your research
interests
hello everyone
yeah hello i am i wanna fortune
um from nigeria
i
actually have a background
in
planned biosystematics
um
my because of my research work during my
doctoral studies
i actually focused more on molecular
studies
of plant species
and since then i've been so interested
in bioinformatics studies
of related species and then
my
my involvement with um
prime biotech
as i joined the honest logic
i've been able to
gain more
knowledge
on
generally on other areas
including the
knowledge on proteomics and
analysis of um
genomic data
so it has been quite interesting
thank you
thank you for watching fair introduction
we'll be starting the session in more
two minutes as i see other participants
joining too let's wait for them to join
and then we'll begin
and meanwhile we begin with today's
session it would be nice if you could
please introduce yourself in the chat
box you can tell us about your
educational research background and also
your research interests
thank you
hello everyone
i would like to welcome you all to the
second session on bioinformatics for
infectious diseases
this program is dedicated to the study
of viral diversity and its role in
epidemic infectious diseases that keeps
re-emerging including zoonotic spillover
transmission between humans and the
process of viral and bacterial disease
development
the participants will get a chance to
learn about bioinformatics
and analyze genomic data by applying
various analysis approaches to study
viral genomes
as a result you will learn to understand
relationships between viral strains and
haplotypes find differences in sequence
data and see the implications for drug
and vaccine design
this program will provide opportunities
to practice analyzing data to gain
hands-on experience with curated data
sets from public domain collections
guided by experts with bioinformatics
experience and knowledge about virology
in the previous session we discussed
about next generation sequencing viral
genomes in host transcriptome
we went through an overview of ngs that
included about reads sequences and file
formats learnt about alignment
annotation and non-mapped reads and
alignment to databases or viral genomes
the
19 experience will almost certainly
change the future of vaccine science it
shows how fast vaccine development can
proceed when there is a true global
emergency and sufficient resources
this wouldn't have been possible without
a proper function healthcare system and
industry
today's session is in collaboration with
prima's life sciences
prema's life sciences is engaged in
delivering a high performance unit in
genomics by establishing brands like
illumina and a few other niche
technologies in the indian market
today we will discuss about ngs for
infectious diseases where we understand
the workflow for designing your ngs
virology project
learn to process your samples and
generate ingest data sets
and then we also learn about virology
public repositories and data sets where
we'll find ngs data from public
repositories and understand the virology
data sets
now i would like to welcome our first
speaker dr abhishek pagela
and he is currently working as a product
manager and r d associate in applied
genomics domain at prima's life sciences
private limited
he is primarily involved in developing
india's market in infectious diseases
and other microbiology domains and is
responsible for the development of
normal ngs based diagnostic solutions
for a few important infectious diseases
in india
we are pleased to have you with us today
sir i would like to now pass on the
stage to you over to you sir
um thank you so very much
for any further for the brief
introduction
and um a very good morning a very good
evening to all the participants uh over
there
and uh so
let me just share my screen
right
uh
okay i have also learned that durably
you people have uh
probably have probably uh understood
about basics of next generation
sequencing in your previous uh
training courses but uh just wanted to
you know uh
start the presentation
by having a little bit more about
the impact of next generation sequencing
and how
this is very very important in the
current scenario and how declaration
sequencing can be applied for infectious
diseases
so you know we all are aware of the
human genome project which was which
cost
which
for the cost of the project was about 3
billion dollars and it took 13 years to
complete the project and in that
scenario which was about that which is
which is the case of you know when 2010
2001 or 2002
now if you talk about the entire human
genome project sequencing of entire
human genome genome it can be done
within few days within probably a due
with with the dollar with the cost of
about one thousand dollar you know so
that is the advancement of technology we
have and this is because this is this
this is because of the advent of
designation sequencing
and you know
let me just give an example and this is
so
so important that you know whenever you
have to do a whole kind of a genome
sequencing so if you take an example of
a chromosome if you have to take
if you have to sequence
a chromosome for instance you know what
you should be doing essentially would be
chopping off that dna into smaller
fragments and those smaller fragments
are then probably cloned in the vectors
and those vectors will be sequenced and
this was the technology which have been
used in many uh for for say for example
human genome project and in that time so
i'm just putting an example of one
chromosome so one chromosome you will
have 10 000 dna fragments and then you
will have 10 000 clone vectors and all
of them have to be sequenced in a manner
that you know you can probably go for 96
uh sample sequencing at a time and to
complete the entire sequence now
considering this
this particular task of
sequencing the entire chromosome it
would probably take about 24 weeks if
you have to go for sanger sequencing so
in this angular sequencing what is what
exactly you're doing you're basically
uh sequencing uh
all these different clones and it would
probably require a huge amount of money
so consider so the impact of ngs is that
you know with with advent of ngs all
these 10 000 fragments can be sequenced
in a massively parallel sequencing
manner together at the same time in a
very short span of time and with a very
very limited cost you know you can
so this is the power of ngs where you
can do so much of so you have a power of
scalability throughput and the cost so
so this is the this is the kind of
impact you had because of
advent of ngs now
before we really jump to the application
of ngs for inferior diseases let me just
you know brush up your
knowledge about next generation
sequencing so an exhilaration sequencing
as we just discussed there are multiple
technologies
and among all of them illumina is the
one which is
highly efficient and the most adopted
technology throughout the world
now how it works probably you must have
also learned this during the previous
courses but just let me go through once
again that you have a dna you have your
dna which has to be sequenced so what
you do you chop up the dna and have
adapters attached to it
and that and these particular the
fragments they are attached to the uh to
the floor cell and in these what will
you do you will have a bridge
amplification
and then you will have
and what we what basically we do in pcr
that we take we take a dna template and
we try to have pcr primers against a
specific gene and try to amplify that
and go for sequencing that is the case
of next angular sequencing but in case
of ngs where you don't know the sequence
of the genome so you're chopping it off
and trying to you know trying to attach
them to a flow cell and trying to
plurally amplify all of them
and once they are amplified they are
being sequenced by a method called
sequencing by synthesis so and as in
when the differently fluorophore labeled
nucleotides are being added it is being
captured in a high throughput manner and
that is how you know you consider one
particular spot and this particular
cluster so in one in one in one shot you
have a gene in the secondly what is
added is c then followed by t g and a
and that's how the entire dna is being
called for in one particular cluster
likewise you have billions of clusters
and you tend to get
very high throughput data about the
genome sequencing or whatever
application you are you're probably
interested in so now coming to
uh coming to uh the applications you
know
when we talk about uh ngas
we have we have scalability so you know
you can basically try to go for whole
genome sequencing one can go for exam
sequencing and then you can go for
amplicon sequencing we'll try to cover
some of this portion with respect to
infectious diseases whilst anger
sequencing you probably go for single
gene and and you know you have a list of
you have a low scalability for that
now coming to uh infectious diseases so
when we say infectious diseases it's
just not only confined to the viruses
you know you have a plenty of bacteria
fungi parasites you know they all are
caused they the most many of them are
positive agent of you know you know
infection as infectious diseases and if
you look at this particular chart we
have had
huge we have had very tremendously uh
you know uh affect uh what you call the
infection diseases which have affected
the human civilization
uh very very uh significantly and uh one
of them we are experiencing right now
which is kuwait 19 and this is one thing
which is uh this is this is something
which probably
uh now brings uh the entire focus of uh
ngas towards the main uh mainstream um
signs
now infectious diseases they they can be
pop they can be pulsed from person to
person and some are transmitted by
insects or animal bites and then some
are because of contaminated foods and
there are many more ways one can get in
fish diseases
so what is what is important here is to
understand that how with how one can use
next generation sequencing for
infectious disease diagnosis and
surveillance
so you know this is a very very broad
area of research where
the idea is to that they can be three
different ideas one is the pathogen
identification you know at times what
happens that you know you uh where we
work with the with the clinical samples
that time it is difficult to culture
organisms directly from the clinical
sample and that creates problem and that
becomes you know rate limiting steep for
a very accurate and early diagnosis of
the disease so for that matter uh you
know it is very very important that ngs
can be applied there
and of course what is another important
point is that you know when we have
pathogen identified or when we have
pathogen which we have recovered from
the clinical sample
one can basically look for what kind of
resistant mutations are there for
antibiotics and what kind of a toxins
virulence genes are associated with that
particular organism if the organism is
found to be highly virulent
other than that there's a whole range of
host response which can be studied it's
not only the pathogen which one can try
to study but of course that the most
response can also be started so which is
a different arm of arm altogether coming
to very important area which is you know
the surveillance and which which comes
under epidemiology so we have so there
have been various hospital outbreaks of
uh various infectious diseases and many
outbreaks not only hospitals but in
community also and so angie's has played
a very very important role with respect
to outbreak investigations also and
that's how you know strain
identification is very important when we
try to do outbreak investigation
and
another one is the community structure
when we try to
find out what is the microbiome of of a
given of a given sample say for example
now there have been multiple uh studies
which are linking gut microbiome uh
dysbiosis with uh with various diseases
so this is another area where you know
injustice has got an application
so today what we are going to probably
discuss
is more of a maybe more more towards
pathogen diagnosis and understanding the
resistant mutations and then further how
and how injuries can be applied for for
microbiome analysis
now there are two very broad category of
uh you know the methodology one
basically go for while applying next
generation sequencing for
infectious diseases one is
targeted amplicon sequencing and one is
whole genome sequencing so let me let me
probably revise you about
this
concept called
sextinous ribosomal rna i'm sure many of
you are aware that sexiness ribosomal
rna gene has been classically used
throughout the world for bacterial
identification
you know and and similar to 16s
ribosomal rna gene
there is another gene called internal
transcript spacer region which is called
ids and that has also been classically
used throughout the world for fungal
identification okay so these are the
genes which have been classically used
now
the approach goes this way that when you
know so this target amplicon sequencing
basically
so what what we do in these we know what
is what is a target that means what we
can go for we will try to go for
sixtiness ribosomal on a best approach
for sequencing or maybe its based based
approach for sequencing so in this
situation say for example if you try to
imagine a sample which is say for
example
a sputum sample from there you have um
uh isolated uh
isolated total dna and then try to
amplify
specifically what all bacteria are there
in the sputum so this becomes very
important because you know you are
essentially trying to
enrich
the bacterial dna
while leaving behind the host dna so
this is an advantage so what we do we
try to amplify all the possible bacteria
which are there in the sputum sample and
try to sequence them and find out what
all bacterias are present in the sputum
sample this is just one example i'm just
putting up that way
another approach is volume sequencing
where you have possibly isolated the
bacteria or fungi or virus or what i
mean the virus in the cell culture so
you want to know the whole genome
sequence so that in that situation
the the
the strategy would be different that you
would go for a different strategy so
we'll see how these different approaches
are applied in case of infectious
diseases
now
the the very first disease which we are
going to talk about is of course going
19 because that's what that's that has
changed the way we all live you know and
probably in it has affected
all of us in such in some or other
manner and and
this is the very this is the this is the
timeline what we could see that this has
become such an important disease
particularly in india that we have had
the very high uh load of
uh
koi 19 patients in india and you know
this is something which is which is uh
uh which is uh very very important in a
way that
because of the because of the uh kuwait
19
every other person is aware of of rt pcr
test and every other person is now aware
of whole genome sequencing or genomic
surveillance of sas co2 because of that
the next generation sequencing has been
brought to a center stage where it is
helping the inflation disease specialist
or the policy makers to to make the
decisions you know and uh so in these
particular disease i'm trying to put up
certain statistics uh of of india where
we have very high number of cases of
coronavirus during during during um say
may 2021
and then you know again we had a peak of
omicron in probably in january which is
subsided now so the point is that code
19 as a disease is highly dynamic and
not only dynamic it is evolving so what
we have been essentially doing is to
diagnose the disease and how do we
diagnose the disease by doing kobe 19
antipcr test
okay so there is a difference between
diagnosing a disease and doing a genomic
surveillance because by by diagnosing
the disease you could say that okay
there is a going 19
disease is there but then you might not
be able to tell what variant is causing
the disease so when you talk about all
sorts of variants starting from alpha
beta gamma delta
all these information is possible
through genomic surveillance that means
through genome sequencing of the virus
so here we can here is the era of both
uh the genomic surveillance of saskatoon
wire a susceptible
virus
this is this is very important because
you know the genetic surveillance is why
this is very important because it can
help us to treat the transmission roots
of infectious diseases globally and now
we know how the disease started and how
it has spread
and it you know we will be able to under
we have understood how rapidly the virus
is rotating and then you know there are
certain mutants which there are certain
variants which are probably no more
they they are probably they might um
make vaccines less effective and then
they probably wait diagnose the test
also so so this is very important that
you know we should know
the entire genome sequence of the virus
and and then so that one can identify
which variants are there and based on
the variance one can have proper
strategy for control and contentment of
the disease
and with these respect you know
we we have so so this is this is a
classical example of you know how uh the
workflow goes for genomic surveillance
that you basically isolate rna from the
patient sample and what classical is
being done for kuwait 19 diagnosis is
that qpcr detection and the report but
in case of genomic surveillance we go
for rtbcr pcr and then go for pcr
amplification laboratory preparation
illumina sequencing
sequence analysis which will include
all your different
different strategies of phylogenetics
phylodynamics and variant classification
so that is it that is how we type we
identify what variants are there what
lineages of viruses are there and this
is the this is a classical you know
workflow for a genomic surveillance of
saskatoon virus
now in case of for genomic surveillance
of saskatoon virus illumina has been at
forefront throughout from the beginning
to today
to to date we have been uh probably
serving uh the the
entire uh genomic fraternity for for
genome sequencing of the sas co2 virus
and we have a couple of solutions for
you know for the sequel for sequencing
of sas co2 where we have shotgun meta
genome sequencing enrichment based
panels and then the amplicon amplicon
based panels and in amplicon best
channel we have a kovitsik test this is
a test which has been classed which has
been used in in many of the uh genomic
lab for for so for the genomic
surveillance of sas code to virus
and uh this this is a code sick test
which can actually enable detection and
sequencing of sas core 2 in research
setting and we have a couple of
sequencer where it can be run in uh you
know it can it can be running all these
possible sequencing platforms what we
have
and
you know the the workflow is is is goes
this way that you have rna which is
extracted and then you know we have uh
we have a 98 amplicon
we have to amplify 98 amplicons using
different sets of parameters so there
will be covered sig primer pool one and
premier pool two
these two in in total will amplify 98
amplicons
and that will be sequenced and then we
get the complete genome sequence of the
virus
and then based on the analysis based on
the kovid lineage app we get to know the
what kind of uh which lineage of the
virus is there what which
variant is uh which variant is there so
that that all can be done uh through
this particular end-to-end solution
so this is exactly it goes that we
collect the sample and then here sample
preparation library
sequencing analysis and at the end
report so this is this as i said this is
end-to-end solution for you for the
genomic surveillance of
coronavirus for the for the corona virus
and now you know we we have been seeing
that there have been a lot many
variants which are popping up and then
going going down and and then stuff like
that that you see they have been
variants like alpha beta
we discussed and then recently we had
mikron which was like we had which have
we had huge number of cases in india and
suddenly it has just subsided now you
know but but that's not the end of the
story you know the because the the
coronavirus is having such kind of a
genetic makeup that you know it will
keep mutating and then probably you know
we'll have keep we will have new mutants
uh arising in in future and uh this is
on the right hand right hand side you
would see the
news published very recently in the new
york uh which which talks about that
there is a mysterious kernel virus which
was found in new york city's image
sewage surveillance and they found that
these it has a huge a set of mutations
and those are very unusual mutations so
so you see that the things are not
really have gone down and and you never
know when the wires will come back with
the new set of variants and and that
becomes very very important that we
should keep our guard we should not you
know
uh we should always be equipped should
be prepared for for genomic surveillance
of saskatoon virus in future and in this
particular uh man in this particular um
aspect illumina kovic test is remain the
most important tool for genomic series
of sas co2 virus
now uh in india we have had a very
a consortium of uh indian source for two
genomic consortium where we have a huge
we have a set of laboratories in from
india which are involved in saskatoon uh
genome sequencing and they have been
they have been uh
and if you look at the entire scenario
of sas go to genome sequencing we will
see that in india approximately 93
percent of sequencing is done on
illumina platform and because of its
accuracy and its uh its wide
applicability
now coming to uh and once we get the
data this is has to be uploaded to the
g-set site and probably you must be
aware of this site and uh in case of uh
kuwait seek assay which is uh from
illumina we haven't we have an option uh
we have a option where the data is
updated into gsat and a data analysis
also uh is coupled with gsa probably
raja my the next speaker would be able
to talk more about the analysis part
now this is all about uh the sas go to
virus now you know and there there have
been multiple viruses in past where the
ngs has played a very very crucial role
uh why uh while investigating the
outbreak and why ebola is one of them
probably many of you are aware of that
now uh moving on to uh moving on from
virus to bacteria i think this is
another important area where which is uh
which is which which has got a lot of
attention in the park in the recent time
especially tuberculosis because
tuberculosis uh because what has
happened that in because of the kuwait
19 the entire fight against tuberculosis
has uh has got a setback because of a
lot of lockdowns and stuff like that
so but tuberculosis has remained one of
the very one of the major important
diseases as far as uh developing a world
is concerned and what we see that
tuberculosis obviously we are aware that
is caused by
tuberculosis and most of the cases are
you have pulmonary tuberculosis
but nowadays what you see that there is
there are cases of extrapolative losses
as well
which include intestine meningiti
manages lymph nodes bone joints are
getting the skin
and
there are so much of uh there's so high
number of cases and there's so much
there's so high mortality associated
with disease
and because of the importance of this
disease who has set up a mandate to end
tuberculosis by 2035
and this is an especially to reduce the
burden from at least not complete
elimination at least to 95 percent
reduction db death by 2035.
now uh
what is important you know tuberculosis
has been there for ages what has become
more important that you know what we
have probably more problematic situation
in india that we have about more more
than 24 lakh tuberculosis cases and we
probably report more than 25 percent of
global tv incidences in the world
now this has been there in india for so
many years and then we have been we have
we have had multiple national programs
to eliminate tuberculosis and every and
there are so many stakeholders involved
in that program
but the problem uh is again uh
compounded by emergence of multiple
resistant and extensively resistant
tuberculosis wherein the mycobacterium
tuberculosis is resistant towards a few
set of trucks and that becomes difficult
and then that and that then that become
very difficult to know cure disease and
if you look at the kind of uh load we
have for as far as
mtb or uh as far as microbial the mdr tb
or xdrtp is concerned you could see that
there are we have very high number of
cases of hdrtb and then mdrtb as well so
that becomes problematic now what so
because of this
what what is important now that we need
to diagnose the disease in a very early
stage or we need to diagnose
the mdr tb and xdrtb very accurately so
that one can actually provide better
solution one can prevent the disease and
control the entire uh
cascade
and
now
though so so the what is most important
tb diagnosis
and diagnosis of
a drug resistance in the
microbial tuberculosis these two things
are very very important
now look at the level of uh you know
what we do have it in india that we have
primary health care secondary healthcare
tertiary healthcare
and in order to uh identify or diagnose
the disease
using sputum smear microscopy which is
limited to primary health care and one
can and one has to go for tests for
identified die for diagnosis of mdr and
hdrtb then it is more restricted towards
tertiary care center where you have huge
infrastructure and which is which
requires kind of a biosafety level which
is required for tuberculosis so so you
have we have a problem with respect to
you know diagnosis of disease and with
respect to
identifying
the drug resistant tuberculosis uh uh
the magnetic tuberculosis uh bacteria so
so how this can be further for the this
is one of the problem what we what i
just mentioned
another problem so we are i'm trying to
i'm trying to portray that there are few
problems and how ngs can really help in
in this in the decisive fight against
tuberculosis so you can see what i have
mentioned here that tuberculosis you
have an evolving molecule epidemiology
of mycobacterium tuberculosis so
basically microbial tuberculosis has
originated from say africa just evolved
from africa
and then
it had spread it to uh so it has it has
formed multiple lineages
and these lineages are like kind of a
set of very specific genotypes so these
lineages of mtb so these lineages are
not different species
they so you have same species of
mathematical losses but they are having
different lineages and these lineages
you have say a couple of lineages now
this lineage 2 is more virulent with
high mortality it has high mutation rate
it to acquire drug resistant very fast
so this is a b this is a beijing lineage
which is more predominantly found in uh
china
likewise we have a lineage four which is
more likely to have consolidation in the
lungs and there is a lineage one which
is more likely to present with bilateral
cavitation and lower rates of tb
transmission
and if you look at all these things you
know would you would wonder that even in
india if you look at in india we have
lineage one which is predominant in
south india and the mh3 will be
dominated in north america now this is
very important that you know all these
limitations are very very important to
identify
and
if you look at in india we have set of
lineages so you look at in north india
we have a different lineages so i think
they may have different lineages
compared to eastern and western so these
identification of these lineages is very
important so that you know one can have
a necessary intervention for control of
the of tuberculosis and all these
lineage identification is classically be
done by the genotyping method which is
very cumbersome method and which can
only be performed at tertiary clear
centers where you have a huge
infrastructure and this is
called spoligo typing and then you can
also use some other dot block essay for
that
so now how these things can be really uh
you know taken up by next generation
sequencing
so in india what we see that
other than these problems tuberculosis
we have another issue that we have
there is that we are aware of the fact
that tuberculosis is caused by
mycobacterium tuberculosis
but there are some non-tuberculous
microbacteria are also there
non-tuberculous phytobacteria
are very important because they are
often
been seen as a co-infective agent
with this with mtv
so why this is important this end teams
are important because they are very
resistant they are highly resistant
towards all the conventional
anti-tubercular drugs
so if a patient has an infection of
microbial tuberculosis
and a co-infection of
ntm
and if that patient is being treated for
microbacterium drugs they will the
patient will not respond and it will
keep
it will have the
symptoms and the disease persistent
in that situation it becomes very
important that we need to identify
non-background tuberculosis bacteria as
well
in addition to the main organism that is
mycobacterium tuberculosis now this ntm
is being identified using line probe
assay a line probably is kind of a very
specialized molecular assay which
identified different species of
mycobacterium tuberculosis
now what has been seen that in case of
in india what we see
by applying whole genome sequence
sequencing people have identified that
the co-infection rate of ntm with m
tuberculosis is about 20
and this was the rate which was which
was never detected before because
initially the uh
identification of n team was restricted
towards few centers because this
techniques are specialized now but
because of whole genome sequencing the
illuminati sequencing and teams are also
being identified and because of that the
people are able to get a more accurate
treatment using this kind of an approach
okay now we are aware of a fact that a
micro that mdr tuberculosis that is
multiple resistant tuberculosis
uh uh
is because of the
of the mutations in
drug uh in the the drug target for
repair fantasy and as soon as it
but in india or probably i'm sure it
must be happening in many other parts of
the developing world these do see
various novel mutations
which are there in case of mtb and such
mutations can not be detected by any of
the methods for that we need to go for
or you know next generation sequencing
illumina based next generation
sequencing
and so in this situation what we offer
in acceleration sequencing offers that
one can go for laboratory diagnosis
of tuberculosis bacteria and
non-tuberculosis
mycobacterium so classically this is
being done by doing smear staining or by
doing a bacteric mgit culturing or by
line progressing now another important
point is that we should know whether a
given bacteria so so you know you should
also understand that microbial
tuberculosis culture is very culturing
is very fastidious you know it takes
weeks to grow and
once it takes weeks to grow then once it
is grown then it is being subjected to
physical drug testing to identify
what is what are the drug resistant
mutations in that bacteria that again
takes few weeks to
get the results so in that situation you
know the entire treatment
gets delayed and that basically you know
helps the bacteria to probably spread uh
you know
more efficiently so this is another
issue and with for that also in
classical setting where you don't have
ngs you have to use bacteric mgit or
other some other methodology
and i just mentioned you about that how
lineages are important in case of mgb
and how uh how uh spoligo typing i mean
this is classically done by spoligo
typing but by using ngssa one can do all
these different sets of
analysis in one go and one get a
comprehensive picture of the entire
disease spectrum so that you know
a decision uh can be made very very
promptly by clinician
okay now uh how do we go about that so
for that we have a we have a say called
duplex myc tb so this is a targeted ngs
based person you know so targeted use
based i say that means
we have what we have here we have a
panel of uh
so in these particular this particular
assay it targets
uh it identifies mutation
in
different drug resistance for drug genes
for example
uh are a fantasy isoniazide and
ethambutol the first line antibiotics
you know then you have a second-hand
antibiotics and even the new antibiotics
which are like uh metaquiline or linus
alright so in the through this
particular assay we
we are able to identify mutations in all
those these these drug targets
other than this
there is a there is a
gene called hsp65
so this is used for species
identification that means that one can
identify mycobacterium tuberculosis
not only this but one can also identify
the ntms the non-tuberculous
microbacterium
okay
so in addition to this i mentioned you
about
identifying lineages so there is a panel
for spoligo typing that identifies
lineages and this fallow snips which
identify which is another genotyping
method so through this particular
comprehensive approach we can
simultaneously predict the resistance to
15 entity drugs and also we can identify
different ntms and an mtb
and also identify lineages
and this is a very interesting solution
there the total turnaround time is 48
hours and
most importantly it can be directly
applied to sputum
so you don't have to culture the
bacteria and isolate dna and use this as
a this assay can be directly applied to
sputum
okay and you can have a possibility of
having 34 samples in one go so this is
this is how it goes and you know so you
have a sample preparation this is an
end-to-end solution what we have here so
you know you are aware of the fact that
you know there are a lot of bank a lot
of injurious assays where you have to
uh you know uh have have you have to put
your efforts to for bioinformatic
analysis uh you know but in this
situation when you have dna which is
being uh subjected towards uh library
prep for uh for this nyctb we have a
web-based uh analysis
platform where at the end of the
at the end of the test you get the
entire report
i am showing you a sample report that
you get a
patient name
and the sample type and uh on which
sequencer this sample was run
and what was the method say for example
this is o genome sequencing but you can
probably talk about say uh duplex mic tb
also and then it will talk about
lineages which lineage is that and then
it will tell you
this is resistant towards as soon as it
fantasy and what kind of a mutation is
there that can that kind of information
also one can get so this is something
which is quite uh
i mean a very end-to-end solution as far
as microbial tuberculosis disease is
concerned so
this way you know we will have a very
comprehensive picture for for disease
diagnosis
for uh understanding the epidemiology
of the disease
now
coming to another important area you
know where where we have uh where we
have this um
uh called uh a silent pandemic we have
been listening we have been talking
about sas go to because this is
something which is everybody is aware of
and intimatable resistance is a silent
pandemic because this is
and it is so much so that is
a who has identified it as
one of the biggest threat to the global
health
and it is going to have a tremendous
impact in the years to come you can just
you know imagine a situation in 2050
then up to 10 million death will be
there per year if nothing is done to
to contain the amr problem
and it is going to have so it is going
to have a significant effect
so much so that it is going to affect
the gdp of it of many countries and the
cost involved would be tremendous
so now let me tell you where are the
problems you know you are aware of the
fact that you know
one identity one try to identify amr in
in a clinical setting say for example
you're working on a bloodstream
infection uh and probably working on
staphylococcus aureus or maybe some uh
streptococcus or maybe clay shell or any
other organism and then trying to
probably you have isolated that strain
from isolating those bacteria from the
blood or from clinical samples and then
trying to
uh see uh whether they are having
antibiotics they are having any
resistance towards antibacterial drug so
what we are essentially doing we are
basically at the moment
looking at only one arm of the entire
interval network of amr problem so what
we basically are doing we are basically
in a hospital setting we are trying to
identify whether we have any of these in
amr or antimatter resistant bacteria in
in our bodies especially in legal
samples
and now so so this is a this is one of
the aspect which we we are probably
trying to look at but the picture is
quite wide and it's it's bigger why
because because the problem is that we
have irrational
and irrational use of antibiotics
especially for poultry for animal
farming and and because of this you know
we are probably
trying to propagate or probably induce
amr into the into the bacteria or the
microorganisms which are there in their
gut and these microorganisms directly or
indirectly we consume
and and that basically finally leads to
having the
resistant bacteria
not only about uh these arm of the
amr but then you do see uh irrational
use of various antimicrobial agents in
environment and it probably in
aquaculture also you do see that
and there are multiple ways you you'd
see that the irrational use of
antibiotics and antimicrobial agents so
what becomes important that you know it
is very important not only to screen or
do a surveillance of amr in human
population but also to do a surveillance
in the environment and
there become there there is then here
comes the scope of next generation
sequencing because you know you are
probably if
some of you are aware of the fact that
you know antimicrobial susceptibility
testing is a very cumbersome process and
for not for every bacteria one try to go
for uh physical drug testing so because
in that situation when you have
thousands of bacteria which are isolated
from environmental samples you would
never know whether they are really going
to harbor the international resistant
genes or not on whether it is really
physical practically feasible to go for
physical drug testing of so many
bacteria from environmental samples so
in that situation ngs comes into action
and their ngs can help us in uh
understanding the amr spectrum so there
can be three different scenarios
one scenario is that that you have a
patient which is who has probably a kind
of a bacteria and uh in in the in his
blood or her in his blood and then
somehow the the patient is not
responding to the empirical
antibacterial therapy so what you do you
essentially try to go for genome
sequencing and try to identify what kind
of mutations are there you know
obviously you try to go physical drug
testing but still you know one can go
for uh you know wholesome sequencing to
identify what kind of
uh endometric resistant genes are there
and so that is one thing now
when you do not really have a string
which is isolated from the clinical
sample
what you can go for you can go for
metastatic analysis from clinical sample
directly so this way you would be able
to identify the pathogen directly from
the clinical sample
then at the same time you would be able
to also identify if there are any
antimicrobial resistant genes are there
or not and then that will help us to
understand what kind of a
resistant pattern is there now what is
most important is the environmental
samples where where you cannot do a
physical drug testing for every bacteria
you isolate or every organism you
estimate here it becomes very very
important because in this environmental
samples
we can apply next generation sequencing
based uh the meta genomic analysis and
one can identify whether there is a
presence of antimicrobial resistant
genes in the influence of human or
agriculture activities or west protect
wastewater you know of the cities and if
there are then one can try to locate and
pinpoint
the source of such kind of uh
antimicrobial resistant genes coming i
know coming from they're coming from
which particular settings and then try
to assess the risk of these arg getting
transferred from environmental
commensals to the pathogens so this
becomes very very important and then so
in this regard your ngs can have a
comprehensive genomic solution to trade
the antimatter resistant through shorter
metagenomic analysis or whole genome
sequencing in addition to this in
illumina uh
we have a we have a amr panel with an
illumina where we provide a
comprehensive solution for more than uh
more than 28 different drugs and 490
mutations for for different for
different drug resistant mutations so
that is a comprehensive solution what we
have and which can be directly applied
to any kind of samples which one can go
for and that's how
uh you know the entire uh so once we
know
where from where the
resistance is coming then one can
actually take a decisive step to contain
the resistance and that's how we stop
the uh for the spread of the amr
so this is about this is about amr
now coming to the
last portion of my discussion today is
about the microbiome you know microbiome
has largely been you know we if you look
at microbiome this is now
this is now linked with probably many
many many uh
many disorders maybe many different
conditions starting from decoration to
allergy to neurodegenerative disorders
obesity diabetes and there are many more
especially if you look if you look at
gut you know you're aware of
inflammatory bowel disease where you
know the uh the the gus the gut
symbiosis
dysbiosis occurs because of the
imbalance of microbiome so so this
microbiome analysis can be done uh using
next generation sequencing where one can
go for targeted uh metagenomic analysis
as i mentioned previously using system
establishment gene sequencing or one can
go for shorter metadata analysis
so in this situation if you look at uh
inflammatory bowel disease you know you
have the the main arm of this entire
inflammatory bowel disease is the
dysbiosis of gut microbiota and that has
an interplay with not many boost factors
in the diet and that leads to
inflammatory bone disease and to further
pinpoint
where are the problems you look at this
interesting uh
picture where you have a healthy
microbiota where you have high bacterial
diversity
and
less code overalls richness high fungal
diversity this leads to immune tolerance
and mucosal homeostasis and there is no
ibd
and as and when you have less bacterial
diversity
and then you have more cordovirians
richness
less fungal diversity
it leads to inflammatory response and
mucosal ulceration
and which is associated with ibd
so this is this is this is the impact of
analyzing
the gut microbiome with respect to
various diseases you know
so i think uh uh
with these what we have probably
understood that uh
next generation sequencing has a major
role to play with respect to uh in
facial disease surveillance
and
if we talk about viral diseases
and then other than that then we have a
special disease like tuberculosis where
it has got a role to play especially for
diagnosis and detecting the
drug-resistant mutations
and finally and then also very important
role
which is there in
surveillance detection surveillance of
antimicrobial resistance and lastly in
the case of gut microbiome
so i think with this i would like to
thank you all for your um
for your listening
and then if you have any questions i'll
be very happy to take the questions now
um
can i uh can i stop sharing my slides
yes sir thank you so much for such a
wonderful talk and if any of the
participants have any questions please
feel free to unmute yourself and dr
abhishek will be able to
answer
okay so if you don't have any questions
i would like to now welcome mr raja
vermin kitu where he'll talk about
wirology and help us go through various
public repositories and understand
various data sets
mr raja vermin kitu has completed his
master's in bioinformatics from
shanmukhta art science technology and
research academy
and his expertise lies in bioinformatics
computational biology genomics ngs
comparative genomics and cancer genomics
he is working as a senior technical
officer
at coquilla benthirupa
hospital as well
now i would like to welcome mr raja
vermont over to you sir
yeah thank you so much for for uh
pinewood for giving this chance and i
think abhishek has set up a stage for me
like explaining all the basic things
uh can you just confirm if you can see
my
screen
so it's coming up yes i can see your
screen now
yes so uh my name is raja verman so i am
working in premise life sensors
premaster life sciences as a
bioinformatics specialist so today we
are going to speak about probably we are
going to look into what are the
databases which is relevant to virology
specifically we are going to see
yeah so this is agenda first is we are
going to see basic resources of sas kovi
2
which has been the brief
yes
uh you can hear me right
yes sir we can hear you i think that was
the disturbance in between
yes so there are two things which are
going to see thank you so much yes
yes
yeah
yeah i have
so um two topics we are going to see
first is basic resources of stars kobe 2
another one is infectious world as
so what is our basic resources uh first
of all when it comes kovit there are two
things which we need to look into one is
the global perspective another one is
local when i say global we need to know
uh again i'll be speaking mostly on the
repositories today because that is what
uh we plan right so when i say uh
repository probably the raw data which
will be put up in the ncbi sra site and
then the final output probably goes in
this site and then whatever connotation
softwares will be using or probably the
databases we consider and then in india
particularly how does the submission as
well as the data sources are placed
the first thing is sra sra we all know
probably uh most of the people who are
in uh the ngs domain knows
all the raw data of ngs goes in sra so
sra has you name it any kind of ngs data
it has right
so it's simple you will be creating
account and then you need to fill a form
and then you need to submit your
sequence you will generate a id on so
that's how the sra works again it sra is
basically from as you can see from nih
so it not only has a raw data of ngs
apart from the data as a variant
databases genetic test related again
variantly clinically relevant variant
normal variance and then there is a so
it has multiple resources in one place
these are all relevant to medical
genetics and uh so it has
end i would say probably end to n you
name it any file formats related to ngs
it is having plus you name it any
particular kind of uh studies you can
get those details in essence including
the literature survey publications
clinical trials almost everything
so how does the israe works in general
for the submission people generally go
for
as i told before you will be creating a
login and then you will be submitting as
a user if you see you need to create a
account you need to locate the data set
and then you need to filter it and you
will be downloading again there are
multiple
like ways you can download the resources
and then finally you will be converting
the file
then you can you are ready to go for the
analysis
so how do i locate my data set that is
the first point
so as you can see here this is a ncbi
page and this is a sre tab so i just
type the virus probably the name of the
content which you want to look into in
our case it's like covet so when i the
moment i type in whatever this whatever
the submission so far has been done with
respect to this study it has been listed
as you can see there are this many lists
have been this many numbers has been
seen
the left side if you see
the possible filtrations are available
the more and more filtral we apply based
on the type and then based on the
libraries based on the platforms and
then uh what kind of dataset you want to
have it and like say probably the
resources as well probably this is from
aws right
and what kind of file types you want to
look into so based on the filtration we
apply
right we'll be end up with the relevant
probably less number of data set which
we need
so that's how we locate and filter
second is
we can't use the data which is straight
away which is put up in the sra we need
to go for a tool called fast queue dump
which will be converting the sra file
formats to a fastq file which can be
used for the uh let's say the further
proceeding so that has been done by this
particular kind of commands so once it
has been converted the file will be in
this kind of form
again this is a typical fastq file with
the header sequence and then the again
the kind of same header and then the
quality values right
so that that's what about the
sra so again whatever we discussed it's
not only for kovi for name it any kind
of ngs data set that is the same
procedure it means like say say
next is we are going to see design very
specific to kovi
what is this side we almost know i think
even abhishek have covered very nicely
so this side is basically a submission
to summation database where again we
need to fill up a form we need to give
all the details about the
like source of the sample where it is
processed which chemistry has been used
which machine is being used we will be
giving all the background details of the
data set and then you will be giving a
final data final data when in mind it's
mean it's a fast office right
so what how does the whole thing works
basically decide when you submit it
records and then this particular diagram
which says very clearly is
from the day covet started to still
today how things were being reported
particularly when i say things it means
faster will be getting loaded in their
repository so where does it start what
is origin almost it we can figure out
the source of the sample set as well as
how faster the sample sets were growing
across the group so this particular plot
in fact it's a visual plot i'm just
showing a snap
it captures so it's a visual uh plots
which start from the day one of kovid
has been reported to probably cdc to
still today
how much case is getting reported so
it's basically a trafficking plan which
tells very clearly what is the origin
and where do we stand at this point
second
uh this is again uh it's not just
the repository basically segregated in
the continent and country wise again
when it comes india the major player is
basically
which has been already told before
so uh it has almost all the individual
country segmentation our case it is in
checkout let's see
further i'll be discussing more on that
uh when it comes referencing this is a
probable references which we need to
look into we need you speak about the
sec how does it functions and what are
the key points as it has
next i am switching to a next clay this
is mostly for annotation purpose what
does it does again you'll be submitting
a consensus sequences here when i mean
consensus it means uh the raw data which
we generate probably either beta
surveillance or for even the normal the
sets when you go for sequencing you
obviously mapping with the organ
reference and then you'll be getting a
probably the bam file and then the bam
will be converted to vcf we will be
getting all the variant calling files
and that will be moved to cons like
like consensus faster effect those
consumers faster files will be moved to
next clay
to make sure so basically it's like a
blast search which generally we do using
a simple sequences to map and check what
are the sequence like it's heating with
water sequences same way here with
respect to co covid globally what has
been reported so far will be going for
that kind of heat so it's basically it's
our notation databases which takes a
given individual samples and it
annotates and gives says which
classification it belongs to
so the next clear how does it defines uh
so as you can see here it says the
origin the newer groups whatever is
being uh let's say formed or probably
whichever the classification it belongs
to it gives a very clear currently we
somewhere stands somewhere here so in
that case you can see what is the origin
what are the branches so basically it
tells all the nodes sub nodes and the
branches it belongs to but when you put
in your own sample
it checks with all possible variants
which is there and then it classifies
and tells very clearly which cladding
belongs to that's what the functionality
of this database right
how does the page looks like this is a
page again there are two options you can
go for a web browser if people who are
not comfortable with cli they can
straight away put in the
consensus faster file in this web
browser it gives a clear classification
straight away
the other option is you have option for
going cli you will be downloading
installing in the command line and then
each time when you uh you will be
calling the updated databases in the
background so it annotates and
classifies and gives out right
so
these are all the repository where
you'll be getting the resources
is spangling
pangolin is basically for lineage
classification this is a page for
penguin how does it uh work
so uh probably this font size is small
so
what does the
anglin gives us lineage details so when
i submit the data again the cases remain
same here i'll be submitting the same
consensus file in this particular
database it checks for all possible or
previously reported
sequences and it classifies clearly and
then says which lineages it belongs to
that's a rule it lists almost globally
everything it's it's updated each and
every minute in that case right
the important thing to be noted on this
is
variant of concern right so as you can
see according to them currently the
globe the global scale this these are
all the five are in the top list so the
individually since it's the indian
scenario we are speaking about
the the variant which is important with
respect to indian scenario which is b1
617.2
right
so this this not only gives a number
rather it gives all kind of segments how
does the number got increases got
increases with respect to time frame
what are the variants of space seen so
it gives almost all so these are all the
variants which is responsible for this
classification with respect to countries
how many countries are like wise how
many cases was being reported it gives
all the description behind this
particular
probably the classification right
so that's what about the kovi databases
so we have seen how do we get the raw
data from sra we have seen how do we
classify them using like how do we
submit the final data which is this site
how do we classify using two different
databases right which is next trade and
pangolin
finally we are going to see local local
when i meant it means in indian level
what are the repositories and who are
working with you right
so uh which has been already told it's
in so-called right
so in so-called the repository will be
looking like this again here you will be
feeding in all the details which is
relevant to the sample resource like the
sources of the sample
right as well as the final outputs
who are all the in charge at this
current let's say this point previously
it was just 10 laps and then later at
this stage since the workload got
increased there are much more lapses
been added these are all the final laps
which are all doing the coin sequencing
right
and reporting in the decide
and with respect to indian scenario what
are all the
let's say voc which is a variant of
concerns these are all the alpha beta
gamma delta these are all the main
things which is being
looked into when it comes to
variance of interest for our case these
are other things so these are all the
things are always in the surveillance
tab for us also
right
so when it comes in soccer community
submission part right not only there you
can submit the data even here it is
basically maintained by igib you can see
how many genomes has been recorded how
many classification has been done so far
right and who are all involved in this
like say in the team
so this here you can see the same way
decide whatever the classification we
saw
it is being put up in the igib page as
well repository page with all the
fangling lineages plus what is the
contribution with respect to the time
right
so so far what we have seen is a kovid
story covet story means including the
databases and the repositories right
now we are going to see one of the
classical paper which is being discussed
probably uh it's an open source tool
which very nicely written with respect
to what does the
clinical world should follow so reason
for taking this paper is
they have covered almost all possible
analysis in one go right
so as you can see here it covers not
only the viral it has both it capture
the details of host and the pathogen
that is the first key
and they have considered different kind
of sample type as you can see here plus
they captured in different time frame i
am speaking about the data set first and
the treatment option i say target so it
has almost all the points which is
needed so that we don't miss any single
point from the analysis right
so uh as i told before these are all the
host which is being covered nearly 77
virus and then 33 host has been captured
in one go right for the study so this is
one of the good study probably good
repository i would consider
for any person who would like to explore
all possible ngo solutions in one place
right so there are 22 different assays
and again as a technology if you see
rna6 gypsies it likes it most even
single cell ribosic
lipstick so it has covered the major
things which has been utilizing the
microbial field
and when it comes the repository how
does they how do they place it
they place something like this which is
basically a individual strain wise virus
wise
when you get inside you can see the
respective data set so when i say
influencer they have taken a sample from
the sample study is based on the lung
and then they have did a rna-seq so
expression profiling we can get out of
this the same way for individual tab
when you keep on getting like say
individual folder or probably the
hierarchy wise they are given
so based on your study you can get the
relevant data sets right
so it's not in not only they have
captured the data set rather after the
analysis in the downstream level they
went to differential expression gene
ontology keck pathway splice site
capturing right so they almost captured
all important things and they have put
up for visualization
for the public use right
so these are all the assays as you can
see
literally all possible things has been
captured
right and sample type when i meant it
has almost there are six tabs are there
we are seeing only one of it right so
that many sample types has been captured
probably the cell type has been captured
and again tissue types there are six
tabs we are seeing only one of it so
number wise it's really huge data sets
are very big so that the thing that when
you make a point out of like say any
analysis you do and then when you make a
point like say
key points
when it makes sense only when you have
this kind of data
right so with respect to the data sets
as you see the major databases are
already in place as a repository
analysis wise if you see almost all kind
of analysis is being performed so that
you you you cover all the segments so
that we don't miss any information
and it's a huge repository which is
based on the mysql right when you do the
analysis as you can see again as i told
host virus so you you capture all the
angle probably all the segments
in that way your uh your outputs are
more reliable
and it gives more insights
that's a key point of the whole uh final
like say this particular uh
repository right
so when i meant eagle view what does it
means
i'm not just
looking into one segment and then saying
yeah this is what happening rather i
just get out of the frame and see from
very far so that i get idea of what is
the holistic view you are trying to get
right
so here if you see
the total number of data set is
somewhere closer to this right and
the file format which you are speaking
is somewhere like say these are all the
files we are getting as an output
and as a analysis
like host pathogen interaction dynamic
expression expression like say metavirus
signatures so we are capturing all
possible details including the single
cell right
so this this kind of
the the future vehicle world should be
like multi omics related projects should
be handled so that you can give up you
can get a holistic picture and when you
make a statement to public and it's more
relatable that's a key point which i am
trying to put it over here right
and with that i'm probably closing the
talk if you have any questions you can
shoot
thank you so much sir for such an
insightful talk
uh karl marx i'll be sharing the
recording of the session with you
that will be helpful
and if anyone has any questions please
feel free to ask
okay so i think everyone is
just taking time to absorb the concepts
that we've been through today
okay so you can either reach out to us
on our mail ids and be able to pass the
questions ahead then
if anyone is there
[Music]
so i would like to hear from our mentors
maybe if they would like to uh
give some highlights or discuss about
the session maybe
[Music]
thank you thank you sonalika i mean that
was that was wonderful session by both
abhishek and raja verma
and we enjoyed a lot i mean there was
lots and lots of
information that
i think all the participants are finding
it really difficult to digest and then
they will come up with some of the
questions and i hope we will be equipped
enough to
give them some directions in these
in the topics that you have discussed
in extensively and also in in great
detail also in a very interesting
fashion i i could not account for the
last one and hours how we went through
um
i uh yeah i think
i'm i'm in the same state as as as a
participants i don't have any specific
question in
in in
in effect in detail
um
i have i have some of the questions to
raja raja vermon if i can uh
shoot him
yes yes yeah he spoke about some of the
file conversion on how to take links
from sra and then convert into a fastq
files and etc so these conversions will
they work on a normal computer or do you
need high performance computing for this
so is this space is the space only uh is
the limitation is only on the space or
it's also on the processing power also
yes it's very good question so when it
comes databases since we are speaking
about small organism and cut current
let's say this point so uh
server is not compulsory even the high
end workstation can do what i meant is 2
tb storage with probably 64 gb ram
is fair enough to start with
but
if the iron machines and then you are
going for bulk number of sequencing
probably a like say huge number of
samples then probably the server should
come in picture so when it comes
conversion part yes it can done in the
simple workstation also and the server
also there's no deal only thing is
when the data size is big and then more
samples obviously i don't recommend to
do in the smaller configuration rather
it's better to do in the server yes
yeah perfect thank you very much thank
you okay yeah
um
and yeah i think i think that will be it
that's that's an excellent uh yeah an
overview of what are the different tools
that are available and it tells the
importance and details of um
data that we have within our reach right
all the mo all these data is they're not
hidden somewhere in any anywhere yes
yeah so yes
the important is people generally think
no i have not seen ngs data i don't know
where to get plus where do i start right
so exactly so in that case yeah so
that's the main intention where it's
always out you just you just find it in
the right place that's it
excellent thank you very much you yeah
you made sure that everybody got through
that at this point and and yeah we are
wiser than what we were
if yeah if doctor mohit has anything
else to add or
somalika has anything else to
summarize
thank you so much dr raghav uh it was
actually a very wonderful session and uh
it was very insightful
and i would like to thank dr abhishek
and mr raja varman uh for taking out the
time for this session and um
brainstorming with us and letting us
know about so many fun facts and things
around so thank you so much sir and
we'll be looking forward to having
great sessions with you in future as
well and uh as a part of the symposium
workshops we have a session in march 2
with primals life sciences and we'll be
sharing the details of the scene with
all of you very soon so looking forward
to meeting you all in our sessions ahead
thank you for joining and if you have
any questions please feel free to reach
out to us at
marketing at the related omixlogic.com
let me put the mail id in the chat box
and you can also reach out to us at
support at the refine dot bio and we'll
be there to assist you please make sure
that you have added both of these mail
ids to your contact list or email
address book so that none of the mails
drop in your spam box or promotions box
thank you everyone for joining we'll be
looking forward to meeting you once
again
bye
yeah thanks lord thanks